just talk about casting and finding
these two great actors to play those
roles right from the off we were talking
about Naomi so because I know now we
will roll up her sleeves and get in
amongst it because she comes to Kenya
with me and being a teacher and those
kids you know in Dusek cut they were
like you mark our work you know that
they've done on the in the scenes so it
was I knew she would in I mean I the
whole style of the film was I felt we go
to South Africa we use the communities
that were working with they'll consider
the construction of the film and the
behind the camera but also in front of
the camera so as much we could to have
raw talent in there so places like
stiletto clip town whole communities
those those crowd scenes that you saw
they're real people that are living the
struggle today who know Mandela you know
the struggle have lived it and living it
today in in in modern South Africa so it
was for me it was to being from outside
was really important for me to create a
world where we dropped the audience in
amongst there with the real vibrancy of
the place and that meant dropping the
actors in a dress I love his work he's
subtle beautiful performance very true
completely believed everything that he
does and I had an instinct and there's a
woman called shaking bay who's a UK
casting director she I've got an
interesting you'd really get on with it
ruse and you know he's you know he's I
just think you'd really clicks I mean
him there I went to Stowe and met him
and talked to him and said listen I'm
not gonna I wrote him a letter first
saying I don't want to do it look II
like aversion I don't want to do an
impression I've met these people and
they men and women that knew Mandela
when he was a young guy you know and had
gone out partying with him and newly
like cars and knew he liked clothes and
you he liked women and you know I had
first-hand accounts you know of people
and all these people were saying Mandela
was a star he was like if walk into a
room you'd feel it when I walked in the
room with it it I could feel a you know
is he's a star and
but-but-but not a star in that kind of
but a swarm good man you know and and
that's what everybody was saying you
know so when I said listen the interest
and no one really knows what Mendel look
like as a young guy so you just let me
since he started that this is a role
that I know because I know we've seen
you in the United States is you know
stringer Bell we remember stringer Bell
from the wire and some of us who watch
BBC America we watched John Luther so
this is completely different this is a
real person it's a biopic the approach
on every role is pretty much the same
you know there's a certain amount of
research that you have to do ever the
characters fictional or real you know
because you have to as an actor or my
particular you know sort of approaches
to always understand who that person is
you know even though we have what is on
the script but who is that person 360
what does he like when he's at home what
does he like when the cameras aren't on
him so that approach for Mandela is
exactly the same as it is for you know
stringer or any of the other characters
I've played I think though with Mandela
there is a certain amount of you know
restrictions as to what you can do your
interpretation has to stay within the
realms of you know the real person and
in this if in this instance we had such
a magnanimous man that you know the
realms were very very wide you know but
the truth is as a younger man we don't
know too much about him and so apart
from the fact that Justin thinks that he
and I have things in common
cars women and such you know I had a
certain amount of freedom to sort of
create what we you know an
interpretation of who the young men then
arose and and what I found in my
research was that his presence was
certainly one of his driving forces
through the wind beneath his wings so to
speak you know you know when he decided
to become a law
and become the first black lawyer it was
definitely that sort of presence that
got him into the room that got you know
the the that won the confidence of a
Ceretto that had no idea what a lawyer
was did you know you could fight the law
what are you talking about and so mr.
Mandela's presence was very much what
the ANC found to be appealing and in an
enlisting to him and I mean Mandela is
you know such a world citizen everyone
knows who he is and what he sounds like
so you know it is a bit of
responsibility but you have to ask the
audience to trust me I'm Idris I act and
I want you to trust my interpretation
guided by by what's your name again no
no I didn't have a chance he was sort of
you know very ill at the time he's much
better now thankfully but he was very
ill at the time and just not in the
right you know in the frame to do that
but the foundation were very helpful to
us and the family was very helpful
especially Winnie and the two doors
this was definitely without a doubt the
most challenging role that I've ever
played because of the breadth of time
that I was playing the character over
and also because of the amount of
transitions that windy when he goes to
through I always feel as though when he
is like seven different people in one
people have such polarized opinions
about who she is and he'd speak to one
person and they betray her in one light
and then another in a completely
different light and it was really
difficult for me to kind of create a
comprehensive view of who this an
adhesive view of who this woman was and
so it was a matter of like watching
hours and hours of uncut footage of her
being interviewed reading biographies
written about her interviewing people
who knew her and it
we're watching documentaries about about
the apartheid era because I was in
British and going to South Africa and he
had to really sweat up on their history
and I felt often like a researcher
rather than than an actor you know it
was it was a hell of a lot of work and I
think what really helped me was actually
Idris organized for us to go and have
dinner with Winnie and that was when it
all came together for me because I said
you know how do you want to be portrayed
how do you want people to see you up on
screen and she said look you're the
right person for this role you've been
chosen because you're the right person
for it you will have done your research
all I ask of you is to portray me
faithfully so she kind of gave me carte
blanche to create her as I saw fit and
it was incredibly liberating for me
because up until that point I'd felt
straitjacketed by people's different
people's ideas about how she should be
played and one of the the great things
that I love about acting is to be
totally free that I can use my
imagination to create a character in any
way that I see fit but with a character
that's a living character that's already
made choices then you have to you're
constrained by the choices they've
already made in real life and you have
to do the research to find the emotional
truth and find why they made those
choices but to have her liberate me in
that way and say look do your research
and then you're free was fantastic for
me I mean you were doing a lot of
prosthetic makeup in in in the film was
that said I see you smiling like there's
a lot of makeup a lot of prosthetic I
hate today it just was much better at
dealing with was like ours was it was
that process yeah it was a really hard
thing to do it was roughly I think about
four hours a day for me in the older
stage Mandela which meant you know so
waking up at 3 in the morning and sort
of getting in a chair about four to
start for about five and I did about 40
days of Christine
in sequence or were there some days he
was young Mandela some days old man
secrets he was thrown in right in the D
retreat you know that last shot he was
like in the first day or two
yeah you know there was a really
interesting sort of design process
because you know we had to sort of
design a Mandela that you know we
haven't we you know we can't suddenly go
from Idris a young address' who is
portraying the young Mandela to a older
recognizable Mandela without having to
sort of age me and Mandela in a it was a
really interesting blend of Idris and
this old you know representation of who
we know we we love famously the silver
hair the face the smile the eyes
especially you know and the the
character ended up just looking like my
dad was like let's just make this guy's
my old man you know it was this thing of
not doing an impersonation of him I just
didn't want any you know any of the
actors the guy playing Walter Sisulu
Walter Sisulu
does not look like Tony you know he
doesn't you know Walter Sisulu had a
white father he's a different totally
different looking and it was really
important that right from the right from
the first conversations that we all
heard we're not we're going to come from
the inside out rather than outside in
and I think that kind of helped that the
when we were testing the makeup and
stuff I think that helped kind of just
free as up you know let's be true to the
the men and women that were representing
rather than kind of getting caught up
with a boy I mean my son doesn't voice
of Mandela you know and it doesn't an
impersonation of Mandela a little Joshua
you're not I mean it's like one of the
scenes I was discussing there Justin you
know the scene when I say in the radios
the press conference that you know my
wife and I are going to split and
there's all the journalists
you know ready to come and whatnot and
while we were lining up for the shot I'm
sitting there with prosthetics on we
haven't said I haven't said a word yet
and there's just one extra and she just
looks at me it's just is that a mask you
have Mandela hand him a set of words you
hadn't done any acting and but that's
for the hurt for her she was like oh
I've been waiting here all day and
you're gonna bring out a guy in a rubber
mask and this is Mandela he kidding me
obviously then you know and I did my
scene and now you know she kind of like
well like you say you know felt the
truth of what we were trying to do it
was a slightly different you know sort
of energy I got from her but it's you
know to Justin's point you know that for
me it was tough to do the older Mandela
scenes with a lot of extras because I
was so conscious about the mask and you
know that it didn't look like the real
Mandela which actually I guess just
really sort of burnt a hole in my I'm
not burn a hole but put a fire into my
ambition to want to be real and really
be honest in those scenes you know okay
so I'm a last question in Naomi i'ma
throw the last question at you what do
you think for you was probably one of
the most difficult but I guess a scene
that really stands out for you in the
film that you really loved or part of it
that you really loved doing love scenes
it's her question I'm so proud of this
movie and I'm I was so blown away when I
I finally saw it all cut together you
know it was that I just love I love all
of it you know and I'm so impressed with
Justin's work you know I just think it
really is an extraordinary film and an
extraordinary accomplishment given the
fact that you know alread long walk to
freedom it's a dense book you know it's
its cover covering a huge expanse of
history where there are so many events
and these incredibly complex characters
as well and to distill it in in 200
hours and to do such a brilliant job I
just think is really extraordinary and
not only to do that but to also not make
it seem like a historical lesson which
it doesn't you know it's it's a
beautifully moving film with a love
story at the heart of it and so I I
couldn't pick a theme